uh what it was your because obviously uh
I think that we just went through a
pretty wild historical time with the
pandemic
um
I think that a lot of the people who
question the vaccine are probably like
feeling a little more Vindicated of
recent recent memory but uh from your
perspective someone who's always kind of
spoken about big government and just
[ __ ] you know
what was your thought process now that
we're kind of removed I wouldn't say
we're totally removed right but now that
we've kind of gotten through this
pandemic the the vaccine just all like
it was kind of a weird era of life that
I'm not sure we'll ever see again and
maybe we will I don't know well I mean
when they came out I posted on Twitter
that
um I thought the mandates were
unconstitutional I got into lots of
arguments with that
um I told people that they shouldn't
listen to uh
media personalities and that they should
concern themselves with dealing with
their doctor rather than anybody else
there are people that are
immunocompromised that would have
benefited from that and then there are
people for example that had a high heart
rate like my friend's mother when she
went to go get vaccinated she went to
her doctor first and they said wait a
minute ma'am you have very high blood
pressure this is dangerous let's lower
your blood pressure first then that's
what happened and she was on our end so
she was one of these people that had to
get vaccinated or lose their job but now
which was crazy right but now in in
court in New York Court that they've uh
overturned like I just saw that they're
reinstating all well before we before we
say that that's not actually happening
yet there's been an appeal filed by the
mayor so the mayor is going to appeal it
because I saw that they were going to
try to pay them some bags no no just for
the people that are watching at home
they fought the 911 First Responders for
20 years you think that they're going to
get their pockets tapped by a handful of
people no the city is ruthless okay
these people are monsters these are
they're animals like when I say that my
friend Eton Edwards who was on Fox on
NBC he was on all these companies
um he's a survival expert and when he
went down and was helping to pull people
out of the rubble on 911 he was in a
full hazmat suit Kev who told me he was
like and he was yelling at the police
officials he's like look dude why are
you giving these firefighters and cops
these [ __ ] [ __ ] breathers why are you
giving them like a [ __ ] n95 that
doesn't help in there's radioactive
chemicals in the air like there's actual
911 syndrome now people have this
corrosive chemical in their lungs
because they don't actually have a
conversation about what was in those
floors those buildings yeah bureaucracy
of the politics of it I mean I think
that's a big uh Jon Stewart's a big
proponent of trying to get help to I
mean if people maybe have seen some of
the viral moments of John screaming at
politicians like but yeah it's crazy
it's crazy if like you can't take care
of the people the biggest tragedy in the
history of our country really you know